zizi c'est pas
[Musique]
le zozio
vous avez écrit un livre
qui s'appelle précis d'astrologie
sexuelle et comme je viens de la ville
de phrase de Vienne je me suis tournée
vers l'astrologie sexuelle pour chaque
signe il y a la description de
l'individu
moi qui suis taureau par exemple
même d'écrire
alors vous avez le ventre parfaitement
rond n'est ce pas
les fesses vulcaniennes alors c'est un
peu regarder dans les dans l'équipe
planétaire après
le poil rugueux comme du crin beau pubis
charnue je vous laisserai 20 le sexe de
l'homme gros et court avec une marque
sur les testicules
le robinet
c'est un peu
on peut pas dire le sexe
ça ne passera pas
le robinet
ou alors vous l'avez gros et court avec
une marque
zizi c'est pas
le zozio
[Musique]
allez-y on reprend le zozio
pour la télévision gros et court avec
une marque sur les testicules ça passe
difficilement aussi on peut pas dire
autre chose aussi
alors
Zodio pour la télévision large et rouge
c'est la fin qui est embêtant
avec une nappe
et tu laisses la femme
et puis j'enchaîne tout de suite gros et
court avec une marque oui parce que ça
peut pas passer
à la télé c'est un peu dur c'est pas un
autre mot
non laisse tomber sur les tests
avec une marque sur les joujoux
allez-y alors vous avez en tant que
taureau vous avez sûrement les seins où
est important même les hommes ont des
mamelles le ventre parfaitement rond le
nombril spatiaux en cercle concentrique
régulier le
oiseau si vous voulez pour la télévision
gros et court avec une marque
sur les bijoux
les chouchous si je vous dis que
Monsieur poignetowski et taureau avec
ascendance bélier
j'ai justement j'ai senti ici que j'ai
trouvé dans une revue on a vu tout à
l'heure que la petite chose c'est le
taureau et gros et court ça doit à mon
avis bien correspondre à Monsieur
ponyovski
monsieur
[Musique]
mon gros il court ça doit être un
fonceur dans la chose président Giscard
d'Estaing et verseau ascendant vierge
oui
Giscard doit avoir l'excitation
purement cérébrale il se monte à cinéma
d'enfer pour conclure tout en laissant
caresser sans fin les yeux fermés
de Giscard je le verrai
plutôt intérêt long et
subtil
vu son signe solaire Verseau Mitterrand
je joue bien égal à la grecque
en plus il doit aimer le faire dans le
noir monsieur marcher marcher c'est
c'est bien c'est son zozio rondouiller
Poupard Jacques Chirac ça doit être un
grand séducteur parce que sa maison 8
est en Balin les yeux de Chirac il est
long élégant beau joli qui séduit toutes
les femmes il a un côté comment vous
dire un peu Bonaparte vous savez
trousseur de servant
les meilleures garanties si c'était pour
faire une élection de plus beaux yeux
d'entre les deux je crois que ce serait
Chirac qui l'emporterait avec sa vigueur
et
son socio profond avec beaucoup d'avance
avec beaucoup d'avance je crois
donc c'est votre pronostic
sur ce plan-là oui je vous remercie
[Musique]